since premiering in 2009 pawn stars has
featured an
endless array of movie props owner rick
his son big haas
and friend chumley have checked out
everything from lightsabers to pop-up
books to famous cars
here are some of the most epic movie
props ever seen on pawn stars
while pawn stars has featured plenty of
star wars memorabilia over the years a
collection from season 17
takes the cake it includes luke
skywalker's lightsaber from return of
the jedi an original poster
signed by the main cast and the original
handwritten script signed by filmmaker
george lucas himself
in an unusual move rick travels all the
way to london to the studio where much
of the iconic original trilogy was
filmed to meet with a guy who preserves
star wars memorabilia despite the seller
bringing out the lightsaber and script
to show off they aren't actually for
sale but luckily for rick the poster is
the possibly one of a kind item signed
by the trifecta of mark hamill carrie
fisher and harrison ford plus others is
estimated to be worth a whopping fifty
thousand dollars
given that the pawn star's patrol always
haggles for the best possible price
rick halves that and makes a first offer
of 25 000
after some very polite back and forth
they agree on 34 000
so while rick somehow walked through the
doors a lukewarm star wars fan he leaves
feeling like the force will be with him
when he resells the poster
money is all that you love then that's
what you'll receive
in season 14 a seller comes into the
pawn star's shop with what he says is
the only caped costume worn by
christopher reeve in the original 1978
superman movie and a kryptonite crystal
however both these items lead to a bit
of squabbling
first of all rick and big hoss debate
whether or not reeve should be
considered the original superman since a
tv show predated him
next they discuss whether this could
actually be the only bodysuit made for
the movie the seller sticks to his guns
that it's a one-of-a-kind but rick isn't
so sure
in a very rick moment he wonders what if
reeve ate a hot dog during a lunch break
dribbled some mustard on himself and had
to make a quick costume change
this is all small potatoes compared to
the very serious issue big horse flags
the green crystal is not a piece of
kryptonite it's actually the crystal
that created superman's fortress of
solitude
in any case the guys decide they need an
expert opinion and call in hollywood
memorabilia specialist
tal rob who confirms that films never
made just one of anything
there's always a backup after finding an
authentic prop number inside the suit
with the name
c reeve inscribed tal rob concludes that
it's legit
and that it would sell for at least two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars at
auction
problem is the seller wants three
hundred thousand dollars so when rick
only offers him 200 grand the owner has
an understandable response
bye when rick arrives in los angeles to
check out a stash of willy wonka and the
chocolate factory props
you'd think he won a golden ticket the
collection features some of the most
memorable artifacts from the classic
1971 film
including willy wonka's signature hat a
golden ticket
several wonka bars and the centerpiece
of the collection an everlasting
gobstopper when the seller wheels out
the rare items rick is downright giddy
he even goes so far as to take a selfie
while sporting the hat gene wilder war
in the movie he then lets out a deep
sigh while looking longingly at an
original golden ticket which was
actually used on screen
when the everlasting gobstopper is
revealed it's housed in a glass
case causing rick to liken it to seeing
the hope diamond of course he reacted
the way most of us would
i want an everlasting gobstopper me too
and me
bought at auction by the seller the
items were originally owned by julie don
cole the actress who played the petulant
verrucka salt for the entire collection
the seller is asking 725
000 which is too steep for the pawn
stars patriarch but he really wants that
gobstopper the seller is willing to let
it go for one hundred thousand dollars
rick agrees to the price if a wooden
wonka bar is thrown in
in the end they settle on 105 000 for
the two pieces and rick walks away
looking like a kid who just won a
chocolate factory
while in orlando rick gets a lead on
someone selling the 1976 amc pacer seen
in wayne's world's iconic bohemian
rhapsody scene
ah the mirth mobile the pint-sized
powder blue car with flames licking the
sides was featured prominently in the
1992 flick which stars mike myers and
dana carvey as two headbangers who
broadcast a public access show from a
basement
rick is psyched to find that the car
still has the licorice dispenser seen in
the movie and a couple of camera mounts
for shooting the interior scenes but
he's not so thrilled by the overall
condition the card doesn't even run and
needs a lot of work the seller is asking
fifteen thousand dollars but rick thinks
he'll have to invest that much money
just to fix it up
so he offers nine thousand dollars the
seller asks for ten thousand dollars
they meet in the middle at nine thousand
five hundred dollars which was a steal
considering pawn stars had the car
completely restored and resold it the
following year at auction for thirty
seven thousand four hundred dollars
excellent a cocky seller who
unsuccessfully tried to sell rick a
delorean in the past
struts into the pawn star's shop during
season 15 with a screen used cover of
the sports almanac featured in back to
the future part 2.
christopher lloyd who plays mad
scientist doc brown and thomas f wilson
who plays bully biff have signed it but
big haas is quick to point out that the
film's star michael j
fox did not the whole basis of the 1989
movie revolves around the sports almanac
which collects sports statistics from
1950 to 2000 and is used by biff to
alter the past in his favor
it's one of 24 prop almanacs made for
the movie because every time an actor
held one in a scene it would get
wrinkled the cover is authenticated by
the back to the future prop master
however he says the autographs actually
decrease the value which is somewhere
around two thousand five hundred dollars
this makes the seller raise a suspicious
eyebrow because he thinks it's worth
seven thousand five hundred dollars so
when rick offers one thousand five
hundred dollars for the piece the seller
gives him some lip telling him not to
make the same mistake he made with a
delorean offer
to this big huss shakes his hand and
says no to the deal
no yeah what are you deaf and stupid i
said no
possessed doll chucky from 1988's
child's play has probably haunted many
people's dreams so when a seller comes
into the pawn star's shop bearing the
doll chucky was created from
big haas has childhood flashbacks of
being absolutely terrified
thankfully it's the pre-possessed
version of the doll called a good guy
and it's still in the original box
chumley notes that all the dolls were
blown up in the movie so he questions
the props authenticity
and her expert tal robb to weigh in on
the situation after looking the box over
and explaining that numerous additional
dolls were made for the film he's
convinced it's the real deal
however since it was just a background
prop it's not worth as much as say the
knife chucky wheels on screen
the prop doll is estimated to be worth
five thousand dollars at auction
that's bad news for the seller who was
hoping for eight grand and the news gets
even worse says big hoss only offers to
pay two thousand dollars
no deal is struck and the seller walks
letting house breathe a sigh of relief
that he won't have to see chucky again
i'll be back i always come back
in season six of pawn stars a seller
brings in a bat-shaped weapon called a
batarang and a pop-up book riddle that
jim carrey used as the riddler in the
1995 val kilmer led batman forever
while the movie was a box office success
it was widely panned by both critics and
fans alike big hoss immediately passes
on the batarang because the seller wants
one thousand dollars for it but he's
intrigued by the cool looking
one-of-a-kind pop-up riddle because it
will appeal to both movie and comic book
fans
throughout the movie the riddler leaves
different pop-up clues for batman to
solve and this was one that actually
changed hands between the actors
the seller wants five thousand dollars
just for the book but big house has
other plans
let's get real he's willing to shell out
two thousand two hundred dollars and not
a penny more
haas doesn't want to spend a lot of
money on a prop from a film that he says
people didn't even like the seller ends
up declining haas's offer and closes the
book on his pawn star's experience
when chumley gets a lead on some props
from terminator 3 rise of the machines
he drags rick to los angeles with him to
take a look at his discovery rick is a
little nervous about what he's gotten
himself into because you never know with
chum but he's pleasantly surprised when
he's shown
three partial robotic torsos that
appeared in the 2003 arnold
schwarzenegger film the props were seen
in the background of fictional companies
crs's manufacturing facility where an
army of robots is being built although
rick calls them dated he's still
intrigued while the torsos weren't
featured props he believes that even
casual terminator fans will
recognize them and shell out some cash
when the seller asks for five thousand
five hundred dollars a piece
rick calls in an expert the actual prop
master from the movie
she estimates them to be worth about
four thousand dollars each
after some audible sighing and light
haggling rick buys one for three
thousand one hundred dollars and he even
seems happy with chumley
my database does not encompass the
dynamics of human peer bonding
anyone who's seen austin power's
international man of mystery remembers
his cryogenic chamber in which he was
frozen before reigniting his feud with
his nemesis dr evil so when fanboy
chumley hears it's for sale he heads to
la to see the life-size
prop in person of course once he's there
chumley can't help but get inside the
chamber and
imitate austin power's star mike myers
somehow the seller has never seen the
film but that doesn't stop him from
requesting a hefty sum for the prop
[Music]
1 million dollars well actually he only
asks eight thousand five hundred dollars
for the piece but that still seems steep
to chumley so he calls in an expert tal
rob
upon inspecting the artifact chumley and
tulrob notice a lot of wear and tear the
austin powers nameplate is missing from
the top of the chamber
and the glass which is actually flimsy
plastic is cracked cloudy and missing
chunks the sheer size and condition will
limit potential buyers so it's valued at
3
500 when chumley and the seller can't
agree on the price he has to walk away
without the groovy prop
luckily his mojo is still intact yeah
baby
rick and chumly go to a star wars super
fan's house to check out his collection
of original movie memorabilia
inside they find an impressive lot that
includes c3po's prototype eyes
a stormtrooper blaster gun and a sarlacc
pit tentacle puppet
used in return of the jedi rick is
definitely intrigued by the prospect of
buying some of the items because as he
puts it star wars fans are the craziest
nuttiest group of people who'll pay
anything for props from their favorite
movies proving his point the seller
admits that he's seen the original 1977
film at least one thousand times
that's impossible even for a computer
when the seller says he wants 80
000 for the whole package rick calls in
an expert who says there's a lot of star
wars knockoffs out in the world but
these are in fact the real deal adding
that the entire lot is probably worth
75 000 based on that info rick initially
offers fifty thousand dollars then bumps
it up to fifty 52 000
ultimately the seller declines saying
that when it comes to price they're a
galaxy far
far away from each other
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one